>> But most traits aren't like eye color right?
>> Right. Most complex traits are actually result
of multiple genetic interactions with an environmental influence.
>> Well going back to our nature and nurture phrase, how do
we know how much of a trait is from nature or from nurture?
>> Well it can be difficult to make a
blanket statement about how much is nature and how much
is nurture. Because there can be a lot of
variability from individual to individual, but what we can do
is look at all the differences in a group of individuals and how much
of that is caused by a genetic influence. This is what we call heritability.
>> Yeah, heritability we talk a lot about that in psychology.
>> Sure, heritability is measured on a scale from zero to
one, where zero means that variation in the trait is not
due to genetics at all, whereas a one indicates the variation
of the trait can be explained completely by genetics. For example,
when people talk about the heritability of
a disease, they're referring to how much
of differences in risk for that disease
across the population is due to genetics.
>> Okay, so it's not the same thing as saying how much of a trait is genetic?
>> Exactly those are two different things, whether or not
a trait is caused genetically versus whether the variability in
a trait is due to genetics. Let's go and take
a look at our example of height again. Suppose we're measuring
height in two different parts of the United States.
Now, let's say in the first population everyone has
a similar economic status. And thus a very similar
lifestyle. But in the second population, people vary a
lot in their economic status and their resulting lifestyles.
How would the heritability of height compare between population
one and two? Do you think it would be the same? Do you think it would be higher
population one? Or do you think it would be higher in population
two? Remember, heritability is measured on a scale from zero to one.